we are very possibly living in the era
of the greatest Supreme Court bench in
American history
that has been true that we are very
possibly in that era since last year's
decision in Dobbs which overruled the
single worst decision in American
history Roe v Wade
but the claim has now gotten some strong
backup since yesterday the Supreme Court
of the United States struck down
affirmative action racial discrimination
in college admissions and as a cherry on
top
the exact losing party
was the liberal lunatics over at Harvard
that was just that just a little L for
Harvard was just a right on top of this
otherwise totally beautiful case already
totally beautiful case the case was
four students for fair admissions
Incorporated versus president and
fellows of Harvard College and the Court
ruled six to three that race-based
admissions programs at Harvard and UNC
violate the equal protection Clause of
the 14th Amendment chief justice Roberts
joined the conservatives and wrote for
the court quote eliminating racial
discrimination means eliminating all of
it
I know
the conservatives are supposed to whine
and complain and constantly lament the
end of the world
but this Supreme Court
thanks to three judges
appointed by one president one president
who was improbably elected after all the
Smart Set political Geniuses said Hope
was lost he didn't have a chance 99
chance the Democrat was going to win
well this supreme court that exists only
as a result of all those things
happening
has officially and significantly changed
the chorus of American history for the
better just when conservatives were
inclined to give up hope we remember an
important lesson heading into Fourth of
July weekend a verse of a very important
song that very often gets left out of
the singing
oh thus be it ever when free men shall
stand between their loved home and the
war's desolation blessed with Victory
and peace May the heaven rescued land
praise the power that hath made and
preserved us a nation then conquer we
must when our cause it is just and this
be our motto in God is our trust and the
Star-Spangled Banner in Triumph shall
wave or the land of the free and the
home of the brave this case overrules a
previous case grudder v Bollinger
this was a case that was decided 23
years ago I think it was I think it was
a 2003 case and at the time that grudder
was decided which upheld affirmative
action in college admissions Sandra Day
O'Connor the nominally Conservative
Republican appointed Justice who often
sided with the libs she said we expect
that 25 years from now the use of racial
preferences will no longer be necessary
so already built in to the upholding of
affirmative action was this idea that
it's going to be time limited and where
do you get that principle from in the
Constitution you don't and it was just
the Supreme Court with the libs and the
squish conservatives shooting from the
hip but now we're almost exactly 25
years later and the court says okay
time's up it wasn't just Sandra Day
O'Connor who though a squish was still
appointed by a republican by Ronald
Reagan but it was even the libs it was
even the liberal icons you know Ruth
Bader Ginsburg at the time of Greta V
Bollinger upholding affirmative action
she still said that it can't be used
forever but it's useful for the time
being to give us the racial outcomes
that we want in society
Justice Thomas at the time made a really
important point that that I haven't
heard a lot of people talk about but it
shows you why these schools are so
insistent up on upholding affirmative
action they were insistent on it not
just because they're liberal ideologues
and they hate white people and they want
to help other racial groups get an
unfair advantage over white people or
whatever it's also because these schools
want to maintain their Prestige and they
recognize that as racial diversity and
inclusion and equity and whatever all
the rest of these ideologies become
important in American life that in order
to continue to train the elite the
people who inevitably will become part
of the elite such so long as this
ideology predominates they need to
bring in more people of these racial
groups that are not doing as well on the
tests and if test scores are the only
thing that matter are are not going to
be admitted to the college in very high
numbers so they're trying to maintain
their Prestige and their hold on
American public life
Thomas went even further Clarence Thomas
in the in the grudder case and he said
that the schools have to pick high
standards or diversity that's that if
they're going to exalt high standards
then they need to stop playing favorites
with the races if they're going to exalt
racial diversity or whatever sexual
diversity or all the other kinds of
diversity for diversity's sake then they
need to stop pretending that they're
they're valuing high standards it's one
or the other they're mutually opposed
here because
even if you say well there obviously
there are plenty of black people who do
very well on tests and who will do very
well in these schools I mean just
Justice Thomas would be a great example
of this it's about the principle that
you're enshrining is college admissions
primarily about high standards or is it
primarily about diversity and ideology
so
today the Supreme Court says affirmative
action gone in college admissions and
don't forget the Supreme Court reads the
polls Supreme Court reads the newspapers
and a majority of Americans 62 percent
overwhelming need not just Republicans
not just white people but a wide
smattering of American people oppose
race-based College admissions
because they all know it seems really
really unfair so now we've got
the opinion we got The Descent we've got
two dueling opinions in the case one
opinion one to send
from the two black members of the
Supreme Court offering very different
visions of race and affirmative action
and the Constitution which we'll get to
in one second first though before I talk
to you about that I need to talk to you
about talking to your friends and your
family which is why you got to check out
pure talk right now head on over to
puretalk.com Knowles I am a very
Discerning partner okay
in my love life my social life in my
professional life I'm Discerning about
the partners that I choose and a company
that I'm proud to stand behind is that
company spread to stand behind us and
our country and offers a great service
is pure talk better announced with a 100
American Workforce they share our
beliefs that is why Pure Talk is the
official cell phone wireless partner of
the daily wire but that's not the only
reason Pure Talk also happens to be the
most Dependable 5G Network in the U.S
they're a top tier provider at a
fraction of the cost of those other woke
companies that don't care about you or
your beliefs mix and match your plans to
fit every person in your family choose
from talk text and 5G data for just 20
bucks a month all the way up to
unlimited data with a mobile hotspot for
55 a month you vote with how you spend
your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that do not support
you instead go to puretalk.com Knowles
you'll get great coverage and save while
you're doing it puretalk.com Knowles
save an additional 50 off your first
month because they value you
puretalk.com Knowles
puretalk Wireless for Americans by
Americans the libs
love Justice katanji Jackson
she's the new one she's the Biden
appointee and katanji Jackson
feisty they like her because she's a
woman they like her because she's black
they like her for all these kind of more
superficial Skin Deep reasons sexual
reasons
and they like her because she's
extremely radical she didn't know what a
woman was she couldn't Define a woman at
her confirmation hearings so I didn't
have very high hopes for her dissent in
this case and my low expectations were
proven correct
here's what she wrote this this is the
part portion of katanji Jackson's
descent that all the libs are sharing
around to say quote with let them eat
cake obliviousness today the majority
pulls the rip cord and announces color
blindness for all by legal Fiat but
deeming race Irrelevant in law does not
make it so in life
and having so detached itself from this
country's actual past and present
experiences the court has now been lured
into interfering with the crucial work
that UNC and other institutions of
Higher Learning
are doing to solve America's real world
problems no one benefits from ignorance
although formal race linked legal
barriers are gone race still matters to
the lived experiences and it's just a
blah blah blah lived experience you know
it's basically my friends Spencer
Cleveland pointed this out he said going
in here
the students bringing the case and the
group bringing the case on behalf of the
students saying hey we don't want to be
discriminated against just because we're
Asian or white they had the law on their
side they had philosophy on their side
they had morality on their side they had
the opinion of the conservative judges
and they said they had the opinion of
very prominent liberal judges and they
said they had they had a pretty good
case and on the on the pro-race
Discrimination side of this case they
had
diversity is our strength the lived
experiences of the racial oppression and
it's just that didn't that was not a
legally persuasive
View and it hasn't persuaded the
majority of the American people the
funniest part of of Justice Jackson's
very silly descent is that first line
of of this section
let them eat cake obliviousness because
what that term does is reveals Justice
Jackson's obliviousness we know she's
oblivious she doesn't know what a woman
is but she's also oblivious to history
because that phrase let them eat cake is
a phrase attributed to Marie Antoinette
when when Marie Antoinette supposedly
was told that the peasants didn't have
bread to eat you said let them eat cake
let them meet brioche but that's a total
fabrication it was made up the line
actually predates Marie Antoinette no
great princess said it it's just fake
it's just total fake news and the libs
fall into their fake news all the time
and they are oblivious to history
and biology
philosophy and the law apparently and so
it's over what does Justice Thomas say
in response to this he answers Jackson
he says accordingly Justice Jackson's
race-infused worldview Falls flat at
each step individuals are the sum of
their unique experiences challenges and
accomplishments what matters is not the
barriers they face but how they choose
to confront them
and their race is not to blame for
everything good or bad that happens in
their lives a contrary myopic worldview
based on individual skin color to the
total exclusion of their personal
choices is nothing short of racial
determinism so true two different
visions of race one conservative from
Justice Thomas one liberal from Justice
Jackson Thomas is a Catholic you can you
can just tell this in his writing in the
way he speaks Justice Thomas says the
Christian view here or specifically a
very Catholic view of the world Justice
Jackson again her religion is just
racial grievance and liberalism and
whining and pride Thomas's hard work
humility gratitude Jackson's Envy
resentment Pride anger Wrath
all the stuff we associate with the libs
and
as has happened now a couple times from
the Supreme Court recently and what
happens rarely in our political life
the good side one boy what a great clip
that was now hey make sure you ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel
see you next time